let's talk about the ad hominem fallacy
ad hominem is short for argumentum ad
hominem which is Latin for argument
against the man or argument against the
person and that's what we're talking
about an ad hominem attack is an attack
on a person making an argument often to
avoid addressing the argument itself
this is another example of an informal
fallacy because ad hominem is a type of
fallacy that deals with the content of
an argument not its form let's say that
John is making an argument and he says
artificial intelligence has the
potential to become smarter than humans
this type of AI could become difficult
for humans to control humanity should
have existential concerns about the
future of AI John's friend Steve
responds by saying John you're just
paranoid that's ridiculous
here Steve is also making an argument in
order to refute what John is saying
Steve's argument is John is making a
claim there's something objectionable
about John John's claim is false this is
an invalid argument John's character
which is to say whether or not John is a
paranoid person has no bearing on his
argument about artificial intelligence
and this is why it's important to
understand the ad hominem fallacy even
if John is what could be described as a
paranoid person this is irrelevant to
the soundness of his argument here about
AI there are several different types of
ad hominem fallacy x' Steve's attack on
John was an example of an abusive ad
hominem and this is how most people
think of ad hominem xan abusive ad
hominem is an attempt to refute someone
by saying something bad about them
another type is the circumstantial ad
hominem this is when someone tries to
refute that claim based on what
consequences that claim might have for
the person making the claim in this case
a person's perceived motivations or
interests are being invoked despite
those things having no relevance to the
soundness of that person's argument
here's an example this guy is a
fundamentalist Christian so we can't
trust what he says about evolution not
being real
I'm fallaciously attacking his
circumstance as a Christian and his
claims about evolution do indeed warrant
their own evaluation and criticism
poisoning the well is a type of ad
hominem where you fallaciously try to
refute someone's claim before the claim
is even made poisoning the well is the
use of an ad hominem before the
disagreement has even been established
in an attempt to discredit one's
opponent oh look Jake Tapper is on TV I
wonder what he's saying probably just
lies everyone knows he's just fake news
guilt by association is another type of
ad hominem also known as the association
fallacy this is where you try to refute
someone's argument simply by associating
them with other people or things that
are negative X is a why X is also a Z
therefore all Y's are Z's Stalin was an
atheist Stalin killed millions of people
atheism is evil another type of ad
hominem attacking a person on the basis
of their inconsistencies
for instance saying that a person's
argument is wrong because they used to
argue the opposite position or saying
that someone is wrong because their
actions don't conform to what they're
arguing this candidates stance on this
issue doesn't make any sense because he
used to have a different stance or this
guy's arguments about red meat being
unhealthy can't be valid because he eats
cheeseburgers but I will add it's not
necessarily fallacious to simply call
someone a hypocrite or
to claim that someone is wishy-washy
about their position on something by
appealing to the inconsistencies of the
behavior or conclusions for example if
someone is very easily swayed by the
opinions of others there may be room to
soundly argue that this person doesn't
have a firm grasp on what they believe
and this is an important point an attack
on someone's character is not always an
ad hominem ad hominem Zoar attacks on a
person's character or circumstance in an
attempt to refute their argument if
you're simply criticizing someone or
something about them that's not
necessarily a fallacy let's look at a
great example of an ad hominem being
used
here Fox News host Tucker Carlson is
interviewing writer Lauren dukka dukka
was trying to make the point that it may
be irrational for people to frame Ivanka
Trump as a noble advocate for women's
issues when she is a direct supporter an
associate of Donald Trump who dukkha
argues does not respect women
what do you disagree with that she has
said what position that she holds do you
disagree with I disagree with her
providing a surrogacy for her father
based on an empowerment of women when
that is an inherent disconnect I don't
think the ad hominem is by dukkha there
is no guilt by association fallacy here
because Ivanka is an ally of Donald
Trump and one could say that who
Ivanka's political allies are and who
she supports might be relevant to
whether Ivanka deserves an image as a
commendable or effective advocate for
women but that's not what I want to talk
about the ad hominem comes with tucker
carlson snidely insinuating with his
tone that lauren dukkha is just not
credible enough to comment on any of
this because she was also writing for
the magazine Teen Vogue here is your
description of the Trump administration
you wrote this piece in Teen Vogue which
I guess you write for Oh which you guess
I write for you yes that's not fake news
that's real news I write for you yes oh
you guessed Tucker you got that's really
nice tonight having read Teen Vogue
because I'm not a bully you have your on
your computers asked me if I wrote for
Teen Vogue you have my Teen Vogue
article in front of you here my name is
Regina and I write Ricky got it before
that point in the conversation dukkha
had sort of pushed Carlson into a corner
with her arguments maybe Tucker Carlson
was feeling like he didn't have any more
sound arguments to use against dukkha I
don't know but here Carlson is basically
implying that Dukas arguments are no
good because she's also being paid to
write for Teen Vogue did your video
parapsychological
I did I also read Liam Payne is a
hundred percent certain one direction
will continue adriana grande rocked the
most epic thigh high boots at Babel
Belle and blac Chyna Arrancar never went
through the messiest break up of 2016
those your other pieces but I'm trying
to get to what you're writing about
Trump Carlson is implying that because
do
also wrote articles about music artists
like one direction and ariana grande
that her arguments here about Ivanka
Trump somehow have less merit but I'm
trying to get to what you're writing
about Trump a break from the thigh high
boots and ask what you mean about him
committing psychological abuse on you
Norman can love ariana grande and her
thigh high boots and they'll just let me
know that I really do guys today who
employs Lauren dukkha is not relevant to
the merit of the arguments she's making
to Tucker Carlson in the Fox News studio
all right I gotta go you should stick to
the thigh high boots you're better at
that Lauren thanks for joining us and ad
hominem happens when someone tries to
refute an argument by attacking the
person making the argument rather than
engaging the person's argument itself do
you want to get better at debating
people you should check out one of my
favorite online learning portals
brilliant which sponsors our critical
thinking mini series brilliant has
fascinating hands-on lessons that allow
you to think and argue more clearly
about political and philosophical issues
check out their lessons on logic
rationality multi-level thinking
identifying false information and
identifying fallacies it's a vibrant
community of over five million members
it brings together the expert knowledge
and experience of students educators and
professionals from all over the world to
create an immersive interactive online
learning environment keeping up with the
news is one thing but you're never
really fully equipped to understand
politics until you've developed a
complete understanding about how the
world at the most fundamental levels
works sign up for free by going to
brilliant org slash critical thinking
I've put a link in the description under
this video and the first 200 people who
visit will get 20% off an annual Premium
Membership visit brilliant org slash
critical thinking